un plan des départementales aux communes
de plus de 25000 habitants
c'est l'objet d'une délibération votée
lors de la dernière séance de 2010 est
montant de l'envelope 40 millions
d'euros en investissements du
département des yvelines est allé sur
2018 et 2019 le département c'est le
partenaire puissant des communes qui
hélas sont en situation délicate parce
qu'elles sont saignés c'est comme une
année après année par les efforts
insensés
nous on essaye de concentrer toutes ses
dépenses et d'aider les communes a
concentré toutes ses dépenses sur des
équipements qui améliorent la qualité de
vie des habitants construction de
logements d'équipements publics ou
encore rénovation des routes des projets
d'infrastructure difficile à financer
seul pour de nombreuses communes une
problématique que connaît bien nicolas
dainville conseiller municipal
d'opposition à la verrière et nouveau
conseiller départemental
il remplace jean michel fourgous et
participait à sa première séance
alors c'est très complémentaire en effet
on a parlé de la verrière on a parlé du
renouvellement urbain
on n'a pas aller affectivement d'un
certain nombre de communes haut que le
département et les communes sont très
complémentaires sur beaucoup de sujets
donc effectivement tout est lié autre
enveloppe destinée aux communes un plan
des moeurs de 30 millions d'euros pour
la rénovation urbaine
objectif aider et soutenir les communes
pour leurs travaux de transformation
dans la tente des subventions de l'état
le programme nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine prévoit l'attribution
de 461 millions d'euros pour sept
projets yvelinois